but i'm curious you've done a lot of
work now um if someone has never seen
anything that you've done what's the
first thing you want them to watch
oh that's a good question
uh oh that is a good question
um
um
i mean assuming that they then go on to
watch everything
of course
uh
i think
uh i don't know
uh
sheesh that is really really difficult
i'd say something
beautiful and
heartfelt and i think just an amazing
work of art maybe atonement
uh by joel wright you direct that the
ian q novel adaptation with kieran
knightley and
many many others um
because that's just maybe the favorite
my favorite film that i've ever been in
to watch i don't know perhaps and then
do something completely opposite like
filth which is depraved and strange and
surreal and um dangerous and
quite
strange yeah uh you were in children of
dune many years ago does that mean that
you dude yes yet again yeah i'm like
well done you're diving deep in all that
kind of sci-fi fun way stuff this is
good right so my question is um how
excited are you for dune oh i'm really
excited i mean i've not only was i in
that i've i've read all those books i've
read his sons prequels i've read the
butler in jihad i've written i've done
it all um i i dove deep into those so
i'm very very excited massively excited
those books get
mental like crazy weird
like trippy psychedelic strange uh by
about book three and four and there's a
lot of book after that as well um but no
i'm really really excited
i may have seen it already and
and i'm just gonna say to you as a
friend and you know someone who i know
you love movies for the love of god see
that in nimax it really is an experience
okay cool i'm definitely gonna do that
thank you it's i wanna stress this it's
phenomenal like it doesn't make sense
how good denis made this movie it's just
an experience wow
when you get out of the theater you'll
be like steve told me this he really was
that good okay
i'm in
um when did you feel like
you
made it enough as an actor that you
could continue to pay rent by just
acting
whoa
what do you know what the reality is
that that happened quite early for me
quite quickly
but the
perception of it didn't come
uh for years so even though i had that
money in the bank and i felt and i and
and the work was coming in on a regular
basis and people would be looking at me
going well you've got a career that any
young actor would love to have
um
it didn't feel real and it didn't feel
or i didn't feel the reality of it i
didn't perceive it as real
um for quite a few years because the
fact is as an actor you can be working
getting all the work in town and then
you then it all dries up and and you
have nothing um
so what's what today is not tomorrow so
it took me quite a few years to feel
that not only can i pay my rent but that
i had a place in the industry that was
relatively safe and that even if the
movies and the tv show stopped calling i
would one day still be able to go and do
theater somewhere anywhere in a
community center and somebody will have
me you know i mean so that took maybe
like five or six years
maybe longer
so jump jumping into my son um
this is a very unusual project because
it in and i really need you so i fully
understand it
your part is improvised and everyone
else's has a script and knows where it's
going
yeah pretty much i mean everybody else
has to work with me a little bit so i'm
coming in with different moves they
might have to adjust a little bit so
they're improvising a little bit
but they have they have the story they
have the script they have certain lines
that they kind of have to get out
and they know where it's going and they
know where i'm going crucially as well
um
and
uh but i'm yeah i'm kind of
learning what the film is about i'm
learning what kind of film i'm in
uh along with the audience so it was
weird it was crazy you know
you've got a a really simple emotive
storyline which is your son is missing
and
um
and
i was given on the first day of the
shoot i was given some coordinates
and
i drove to them at four o'clock in the
morning
in the dark in the mountains of scotland
in the highlands and the coordinates
took me to a ferry terminal and i i
thought okay well i'm going to drive the
car onto the ferry and i drove the car
into the ferry as i'm driving on the
ferry i'm like oh there's the camera
crew okay
this is the beginning of the film
it was crazy it was really really crazy
now i'm assuming you didn't see the
original or you did i luckily i hadn't
seen it
which made the experience um
i guess more pure for me the director
was very keen to preserve the
sanctity of the experience for me um and
luckily i hadn't seen the film i hadn't
even seen the trailer which is
interesting because i was a fan of the
directors before we nearly made a film
called joey noel together uh about the
christmas armistice in world war one
which i think won an oscar for best
foreign language fan maybe
um and then we didn't do it and then uh
jim caddy who i'm a fan of as well was
in this the original with the same
director so it's so surprising it's
lucky that i hadn't seen it because i
would usually check them out but um i
watched the trailer recently for the
french one and it was it was interesting
it was really interesting to see
the crossovers and similarities but it
was a wild ride man like i remember
being asked to do it and i just said yes
immediately and my agent was like do you
want to meet the director i was like
yeah sure but i'm going to do it and
they're like you want to you know
get an idea of what's going on do you
want to watch the trailer for the other
one i'm like absolutely not i'm just
going to do the film and i think
everybody was a bit like you're jumping
in this a bit quickly
uh and i'm just like well come on man
you can you can pay a lot of money to go
and have a 30-minute like experience
where you go and like try and get out of
an escape room and maybe get chased by
zombies and maybe there's a bit where
you have a choice to make and then you
leave and you get a drink to the bar and
this is like this is like the platinum
bespoke vip
just for me two-week version of that
where i just got to live the movie it
was incredible so for example the
director he kept me separate from the
cast he kept me separate from the crew
even though we were all in a bubble a
covered bubble in the same hotel i had
to be separate completely separate so
that nobody would give anything away
and i was a bit like
ah come on i think it's been a bit
extreme here but sure enough like the
first day i walked into the hotel i went
to the office where the production crew
were to get my per diem
and that people were trying to speak to
me and all that kind of and then i saw
the armorer come in
and talk about where they could keep
weapons and things like and i was like
oh god all right so now i know there's
weapons in the film you know i'm like ah
so i i then made sure i had blinkers on
and had earphones on and didn't look at
anybody didn't talk to anybody and all
of that for about that lasted for about
two weeks and then for the last three
days of the shoot i was able to mix with
people because we were just shooting
some action stuff by that point
so i i am so cute as i was watching it i
was wondering there's like a bit where
it sort of goes out of focus a little
bit and it made me realize how many
shots how many things did you redo
because it wasn't in focus or something
got wrong with the camera
not a lot not a lot there was a couple
of things where i don't know let's say i
decided to climb a tree the director
would be like cut that was really
interesting that was a wonderful choice
however we need you to jump down the
cliff side rather than climb up the tree
do you think that's possible and i'd be
like
um
i guess it has to be because the scene
is
left right and he's like
maybe i'm like all right i'll go down
the cliff and so there's a couple of
moments like that but generally speaking
we didn't really redo much at all
maybe
walking into a room sometimes i'd redo
it or you know like set up like driving
up to a building sometimes we can redo
those things because it's not like
you're
you know
those moments it's not like those
moments are
are the
the highly or the essence of the soul of
the experience you know and so
we did those things a couple of times
and some of the action stuff we had to
redo a few times just because you do
with action don't you because people get
hurt otherwise although the first fight
scene i have in the movie was completely
improvised
and i um and it was and it was really
quite that was quite
hard because
i'm in this scene going
hmm
as an actor i'm going i'm about to get
into a fight and i'm like i'm definitely
going to get me a fight and
as a character i'm going i want to get
any fighters on that time going how am i
going to improvise this fight because
i'm like i don't want to just like
tussle can we just like wrestle
two men sort of
wrestling i'm like if i'm going to fight
you i'm going to try and knock your face
off do you know what i mean but at the
same time you don't want to then hurt
fellow actors you know just because of
this cool experience that's not that's
not valid that's not okay
so um
i thought to myself i'm going to throw
this punch as hard as i can but i'm
going to pull it at the last minute then
i'm just going to shout cut and then
we'll figure something out we'll we'll
choreograph it well that didn't go to
plan he he like he flinched the wrong
way
than i expected him to which of course
is completely
to be expected
so i smacked him straight in the mouth
and um
and then it kind of went on from there
and we carried on scuffling and fighting
but um so the you know physically
improvising fight scenes is
almost
ridiculous but
it was part of the experience that
that christian wanted to capture you
know
i know the fight you're talking about
and
i can't imagine it's
i mean for people that don't realize
fights are highly choreographed on set
to done with the ultimate for safety for
all people involved it's really hard
when the other actor has no idea how
you're going to throw the punch what
you're going to do
and you know all it has to be it all has
to be on camera
yeah i know it was crazy so after that
then after that first take where we
captured a lot of real stuff
a fight corner coordinator came in and
we redid a couple of things but by and
large what you see on camera is is what
happened on that first take
so i don't want i don't want to get into
specifics because i want people to watch
it however there is some big
action in big stuff that happens in the
third act and i'm just curious how much
of that was completely improvised how
much was of that was you know figured
out because it's a there's a lot going
on in that third act
yeah no i know um
the
the stuff in the
uh
car
was imp was not improvised that was sort
of choreographed
the stuff with uh the little kind of
game of cat and mouse with me
and the guys in that place uh that was
largely improvised um
there's a bit where i get up on a table
i don't know if that's still in the
movie i can't remember there's a bit
where i get up on the table and i'm like
just well that's
in the movie where you're holding the
thing on the table yeah and i'm like
that i mean i was just certain someone's
going to come in and again i'm like i'm
holding like a lead pipe i'm going to i
don't want to bring this person i mean
then the person
maybe or maybe does not come in but um
yeah it was that was pretty wild that
was really really well
i still can't believe it i mean it's
just
it's just
crazy that you pull you guys pull this
off because as i'm watching it i'm like
some of this ha anyway i'm i um so how
many how many takes were ruined
overall because the director then said
okay this you know what i mean like
um i guess i'm just curious like how it
how he inserted the story onto the
performance and how he shaped it if you
know what i mean
yeah um i think there weren't that many
takes that were ruined there was like
maybe a couple like four or five times
what he said to me i am so sorry that we
can't go with your instinct your
instinct is like
the movie lies in a different direction
and and i would love to be able to sort
of bend the movie to you right now but
it's kind of impossible if you don't
make a different decision so would you
like to improvise the scene again and
he'd maybe kind of give me a pointer but
generally just hope that i'd sort of by
instinct realize that
i had to do something else and you know
there were pointers you know i mean
you'd walk into a room and you've got
two cameras here you'd be aware that
your stage was over here you know i mean
like you wouldn't go well i'm gonna go
act in the bathroom and
i don't care numbers can't see me do you
know what i mean so like there was there
was
you know your craft leads you to
figure out where you've got to do what
you've got to do but um but by and large
he would either bend to me or um or i
would just get
the drive and the motion of the film and
be swept along with it in the right
direction as well
um i got two last things for you because
i'm i got a rap um
when you obviously you like to prepare
as an actor for whatever you're going to
do but without a script
well i'd like to think so but you know
but anyway so but how do you prepare for
a character and a shoot when you have no
idea where it's going to go
well look like the truth is
christian said to me
i want you to do this because whenever
i'm watching you i feel like i never
know what you're going to do next i feel
like you're just off the cuff coming up
your stuff and like all that and i was
like uh
kind of the opposite is true
um i'm quite a i'm quite a
considered um
thoughtful planned out actor like i try
and do the things that i mean to do i
try and do them as well as i can and
then sometimes something interesting
that i didn't expect comes and that's
great but it all comes from
this is the story i want to tell this is
how i've planned that i want to tell it
um
so the act actually i was like oh god i
don't think i'm quite the actor you
think i am but uh but it will be a good
challenge for me because it was a
complete opposite from what i do usually
do which is not necessarily prepare like
people think actors do like in terms of
like researching getting into the
character and all that kind of stuff
but um just in terms of plotting out my
performance you know
um so i wasn't able to do any of that i
got a page and a half of information
telling me who i was where i was from
how my childhood was spent with my
relationship with my parents was like
what my relationship with my former
partner was like what my career has been
like um the breakup or between me my
former partner and the australization
between me and my son because i've not
really seen him in years and um
and
how i'm somebody who
um
compartmentalizes and can detach and
not really and is it okay not being that
caring a father and that's really what i
had to go on and nothing else
it's
um my last thing for you i'm a fan of
his dark materials and um
yeah i've seen it all my girlfriend and
i both like it um so i'm just i'm just
curious where what's going on with
season three
are you filming it or have you rapped i
don't even know filmed i've done about
seven weeks on it um and i've got
another three or forty due november um
yeah i mean i've been loving it i had a
whole thing built into season two which
got
got busted by covered um so really my
all my stuff is in season three now um
i'm loving it absolutely loving it love
getting to run around with the snow
leopard uh also known as amber rose
perry who's an amazing puppeteer um
and getting to work with some incredible
people
and just tell that story that that
really bold quite
right times controversial story as well
um especially into what happens at the
end season three so that's it's exciting
to be a part of it
my last thing for you but i just got to
ask you i really am as you know a big
fan of your work and i just want to know
how going back to glass and split there
are scenes where you are playing
multiple people
in you know like the multiple
personalities
how exactly did you prepare for that
because as i watch your performance
you know i'm just literally blown away
by how you pulled that off how long
before you were filming were you
practicing this to to do it on screen
split not very long i had like about a
week and a half two weeks um because i
think it was working phoenix was doing
it before i did it and then he backed
out for some reason
um so and then the second one i had
longer but i also had twice it more than
twice the amount of characters to do
and really just
i don't know just figure out who each of
them are what each of them sound like
which the move like figure out why each
of them is there why what each of them
wants and then do what i usually do
which is just plot how they are relevant
and how they are
what are they doing to help tell the
story and then try and
use that as much as possible to make
their
time on screen valid which is really
what
like you're always trying to do
with any character you know i mean like
the the audience's attention is finite
every second you're doing stuff every
second you're on screen you're using up
their attention so you've kind of got to
validate every single moment that you're
doing something on your own screen and
if there isn't a validation for it then
they shouldn't be on screen and i
struggle with that as an actor sometimes
because quite often you find yourself on
screen going
i
i don't know why this scene exists i
don't know
why i'm saying anything right now
because none of it's driving the story
forward or
none of it's forcing the audience to
watch further and
you
you if it isn't there on the page then
you've you've got to try and fill that
with some kind of vibrancy or
entertainment or
or nuance or something you know so
that's sort of just doing what i usually
do with all my characters but doing it
with 20 odd characters rather than just
one you know
by the way um i know that joaquin would
have been good but i don't know how he i
don't know how he would have been better
than you because i really think your
performance especially in the last one
is just [ __ ] great sorry for my
language thanks man no i don't mind i
swear to all of them and thank you very
much man you're very kind listen he's an
incredible actor i'd almost love to see
him do it i think it'd be a different
kind of thing but it would be
he's brilliant i'm sure he'd do amazing
uh i gotta stop congrats on this i
thought you did a great job and um as
you know man if i can help with anything
on collider please let me know you know
and happy to help
thank you very much very good cheers man
cool man i'll catch you later take care
bye
you